[Applaudissements]
le col pas trop
tu fais ça voilà là
mais c'est pas mal comme ça aussi vous
êtes beaux vous êtes bronzés
quel genre de produit vous utilisez
alors on m'a fait aujourd'hui on m'a
hydrater le cheveu comment avec tes
crèmes brésiliennes je vais dans un
salon incroyablement hydrater le cheveu
de 15 heures à 19h
elles étaient 12 sur vos cheveux
et la peau la peau
d'ailleurs avant de commencer ma
chronique j'ai un petit problème à
régler avec vous avec moi ouais donc tu
es en train de me dire comment
s'embrouiller oh c'est possible tu
connais beaucoup de gens qui vont voir
leur patron et qui vont à s'embrouiller
je vous le dis je vous le dis oui parce
que vous savez que je regarde ce qui se
passe pendant les pubs ouais les pubs
figurez-vous que je parlais tout seul
parle de moi et de tout le bien qui
pense de moi
c'est hyper sympa et euh vous me
reconnaissez des qualités que je vais
sûrement mettre dans mon CV si je vous
montre ça ça vous fait penser à quelque
chose
parce que visiblement selon Cyril je
suis le laxatif de la semaine vous allez
comprendre pourquoi
le laxatif de la semaine
[Musique]
je dis
qu'est-ce qu'on a chronique chaque fois
qu'ils viennent donne envie de Liège
je l'adore
vous savez pourquoi est-ce que je suis
heureux de vous voir et ça vous détend
exactement
je suis heureux de te voir
des petits papillons dans le ventre
plutôt que ça descende bon alors on
passe vous savez alors en approche la
fin de la saison on est on est fin mai
et qui dit fin de saison on dit on va
élire un petit peu les meilleurs
chroniques et pour la chronique est
terminée alors
figurez-vous que le meilleur chroniqueur
n'a fait que deux émissions cette saison
alors il est direct entré au panthéon de
la darka une sortie une connerie mais je
l'adore c'est Nicolas perdu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
mais il y en a également hors antenne et
ça vous les voyez pas à la maison mais
donc je suis payé pour ça il y a des
yaourts sur cette table qui font des
blagues mais des blagues qui ne font
rire que ah oui c'est vrai le périmètre
le périmètre
faites attention
tous les bons animateurs je suis désolé
donc il faut faire des blagues qui me
font rire que mais ils essayent de
trouver des moyens pour faire comme si
pas Jean-Michel c'est un de vos très
proches
le ni vu ni connu de la semaine
dernièrement on passe au préjugés
malodorant de son directeur commercial
une entreprise
et son licenciement la société lui a
notamment reproché son comportement
d'hygiène et d'avoir laissé les
toilettes dans un état
[Applaudissements]
c'est extraordinaire
j'adore et donc
c'est déjà pas mal parce que Raymond
vous faites des vannes mais en fait pas
du tout quoi enfin vous passez à autre
chose comme si rien n'était quoi je sais
pas qu'est-ce qui se passe
dans un instant mais d'abord il y a un
mec qui se croit complètement
irrésistible autour de cette table et la
Cyril j'ai un énorme dossier pour moi
c'est un des plus gros depuis le début
de l'indique il y en a qui m'envoie des
photos
et qui se croit beau gosse
mais en fait c'est Hugo cassos c'est
madame si vous croyez que cette photo
est vraie ou pas
bien sûr vous trouvez ça normal oui
est-ce que vous avez pas pris un peu de
monde
merci Cyril non mais parce que là les
vœux chez tous les
les matins
bonjour Ma Castaldi est-ce que vous avez
pas un petit peu pris le melon en ce
moment déjà que c'était déjà pas mal je
n'ai jamais eu le melon j'ai jamais eu
le melon bon on va voir avec le magnéto
qui suit j'espère que Aurore ne regarde
pas la télé c'est le melon de la semaine
le melon de la semaine
tu aurais pu pécho
tu aurais pu faire une histoire avec lui
[Applaudissements]
donc c'est bon
j'ai le numéro de la personne au cas où
hein si vous voulez
une très belle
si vous voulez
alors en fait mais alors c'est pas cette
bougaliste là
mais non mais on va pas passer la
journée
[Rires]
alors d'abord oui alors justement
une jeune femme Gilles qui travaille
maintenant je vous jure que c'est vrai
un peu de télé c'était l'assistante
d'Angela Lorraine
c'est l'actrice et tu n'oses pas le dire
devant
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas grave je vous jure que c'est
vrai c'est pas vrai
non non j'oublie son nom je retrouve pas
son nom là
n'importe quoi tu me cherches
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est pas du tout
ouais
très sympa exactement
on n'a pas son numéro Yasmine non non
mais non mais non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu dois me remettre
c'est une petite place au sein de
l'audiovisuel français
[Rires]
je suis avec un garçon qui est encore
des sentiments pour toi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Yasmine
je t'apprécie énormément tu sais depuis
toutes ces années je te trouve
formidable donc si tu peux me rappeler
pour éclaircir cette affaire je sais
qu'aujourd'hui bien sûr tu es passé à
autre chose et que tu as tu as des
enfants tu as une famille tu vois un
mari et que toi tu es voilà droite dans
tes bottes contrairement
mais Yasmine mon numéro est toujours
ouverte tu peux m'appeler 24 24 pour
parler de cette affaire Yasmine Mobilis
à tout de suite
vous savez vous savez ce que j'aime dans
cette dans cette chaîne c'est la seule
chaîne vous savez qui m'a envoyé le
numéro de la semaine le président de la
chaîne Franck Appietto
il y a que sur cette
cette chaîne
merci beaucoup
de la merde
les chéris on va [__] la merde
[Rires]
c'est bon vas-y attends attends
je peux en prendre bien sûr ok donc ce
que je respecte un peu la frontière
la Suisse sur insta Yasmine
[Musique]
bientôt vous allez voir des déroulants
de la rue des Ternes
pour équilibrer un peu
il fait le malin mais on va parler de
lui
du
patronseurs 4 milieux et deux attaquants
alors c'est une composition plutôt
stratège maline
plutôt offensive qu'est-ce que tu as là
oui j'ai l'impression Cyril que vous
êtes plus qu'un 4x42 j'ai l'impression
que vous êtes le José Mourinho de la
teub
[Rires]
d'accord
je confirme je conseille dans une
entreprise
terminée
en formule plus soutenue vous êtes le
malinx le lynx de la semaine non
le malinx le lynx de la semaine
le cul ça me dégoûte non mais moi tu
peux partir une semaine en vacances avec
moi jour et nuit tu dors avec moi il se
passera rien je suis pas dans la suite
pas là-dedans je ne suis pas là-dedans
en dehors dans le même lit et tout il
dormait dans le même niveau intelligence
tu fais quoi toi la semaine prochaine
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
envoie des fleurs à une autre femme
on va attendre de voir ce qu'elle dit
parce que je suis pas sûr que tu es
envoyé qu'une fois des fleurs une seule
fois
non merci non merci
j'aurais un petit mot gentil voilà
d'accord
ça allait très loin quand même
je pense que vous d'accord avec moi il
dégoûte tout le monde
dit c'est un truc
[Applaudissements]
les SMS c'était pas très gentleman on me
l'a dit ah oui on me l'a dit quand on a
fait ce magnéto
[Musique]
arrête de le mettre dans la soupe
voilà avec des emojis
[Rires]
c'est possible
on passe à l'engrainer de la semaine
pas de nouvelles pour l'instant
la semaine dernière c'est justement en
parlant de Castaldi vous avez voulu le
piéger en invitant sur le plateau un
gars qui avait soi-disant inventé une
machine à café pour les VPC c'est
incroyable
c'était évidemment un comédien donc vous
avez en fait que l'été secrétaire n'ont
pas vu c'est que pendant la pub cyril a
chauffé Benjamin pour qu'il déboîte
cette personne en plateau mais juste
pourquoi juste juste pour que sa petite
fripouille ça en fait juste pour se
taper un petit délire c'est l'entraîneur
de la semaine
l'engreneur de la semaine
mon gars
la machine à café pour VTC est-ce que je
mange pas à la machine à café pour VTC
je dis ça mais c'est quoi cette merde
vous lui dites
[Musique]
là vous commencez votre stratagème en
étant non espoir comme d'hab vous avez
un truc un menteur du café pour VTC donc
je veux savoir ce que c'est parce que
j'en parlais tout à l'heure je dis que
l'invention était super à la à la pub
j'ai dit vous allez voir il y a un
inventeur qui est super mais j'ai pas
j'ai pas j'ai pas compris vous allez me
dire ça dans un instant le problème à
chaque fois avec vous Cyril c'est que
les canulars vous ne savez pas les tenir
vous êtes obligé de rire de rendre des
vélos normaux en vélo électrique on ne
modifie
on ne modifions que les roues cette
année
371 inventions
c'est encore faux l'Agence pour la
transition écologique et catégorique il
n'existe pas de taxe carbone de ce type
dans les tuyaux législatifs à ce stage
alors que nous sommes assommés depuis
1h30 par tout près de chiffres et
Perpignan commerciaux il dégaine le
fameux dossier de prise en charge totale
évidemment Cyril gagne toujours le piège
se renferme sur castain vous êtes
vraiment un petit bâtard en bas vous en
pensez vous je vois pas l'intérêt mais
en même temps
[Rires]
une machine à créer le pourcentage des
conneries
ça vous a suffi vous voulez une machine
à répartir aussi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bravo Benji
incroyable avant de repartir Cyril si je
vous dis judoka est karaté
quand vous étiez là aussi vous avez
entendu ce bail de judoka
mais vous allez comprendre pourquoi
parce que pour comprendre la vanne il
faut du temps beaucoup de temps et même
vous à la maison vous allez avoir besoin
de beaucoup de temps parce que Cyril a
mis huit plombes avant de comprendre la
vanne on a été picoré dans tous les ans
parce que vous voyez pas très bien c'est
le Kamoulox de la semaine j'adore ça
le camoulox de la semaine de
[Musique]
bravo bravo il vaut mieux être un judoka
un karaté
bon bah on a toujours pas trouvé
peut-être que Soraya la coiffeuse à la
solution à cette blague c'est un judoka
qu'un karaté
bah c'est pareil
non mais attends c'est quoi le truc
c'est pareil mais judokai c'est les
mêmes
maintenant ils vont demander à Benaim
qui regardait fait semblant d'avoir
compris
il est où
[Musique]
[Rires]
bon allez on rappelle l'auteur de la
même pour qu'il nous explique un peu
quand même
par exemple moi j'ai raté
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]